What are your thoughts on high dose hypermectin?
Dr. Baptist, Canadian, and D wrote this 2017 Mexican study,
showed a work better than chemo for breast cancer.
He also gives guidelines on dosage for various cancers.
I'm a big fan of hypermectin and bedvandisol for cancers.
I understand that both bedvandisol and hypermectin
would be considered in a parasitic as far as how it works and why
would be prescribed.
The function completely different as far as cancer goes.
And hypermectin and bedvandisol would be two different protocols.
And some people think that well, hypermectin works
and bedvandisol works because cancer is from a parasite or from a fungus or from a virus.
That's not the mechanism of action.
So it's not because it's killing a parasite and it's testing a parasite.
It all works on cancer totally because it can't have action with cancer.
We have a number of people who use either hypermectin protocol.
I know there is guidelines.
You can google the guidelines on how to use it.
If general, the guideline for use of hypermectin for a virus or infection like COVID,
was 12 milligrams a day for an average weight of 108 or something like that.
But it's based upon kilogram weight.
So the average dose is about 12 milligrams a day for COVID.
But for cancer, it's about five times that much.
So you want to find a source that you're not paying.
Yeah, they had a dose of 1 milligram per kilogram.
So it was like for I weigh 81.
So it would be 80 gram milligrams.
Yeah, dosage daily.
Yeah, that's all right.
So I would say I know that if you could find a prescribing doctor who will give you a prescription
for it that you could get at a compound need pharmacy and get a compounded for you,
that's probably the cheapest way to go.
I know there's other sources that you could buy it like, you know, it's not the black market.
But outside of getting a prescription, you know, because it's such a hard item for,
you know, a possible next pandemic that might be launched on us.
But I think those sources are typically much more expensive.
So if you can get it, and then it's a lot easier to take than taking, you know,
6, 12 milligram capsules, you know, so we get it in one capsule and that dose is in the one,
so we can take the only thing that I would say you have to be careful about,
and this is totally based upon experience with eye-revectant and fentanyl.
You want to keep an eye on your liver markers because it can raise your alkaline
costs, ASD, and ALT, because it can be hard on your liver.
Now that's not everybody, but I've had some people where I had to have the pulse skit
where they go off it for a month, and then their help those liver markers would come back down,
and they'd go back under the months, and keep, you know, running a complete metabolic panel
to see if those start to rise up again, then they go off and go to again.
So you might have the pulse of just keep an eye on that.
That's the only thing that I would recommend.
You really isn't any other side effects.
I've had a couple people with, but men's all have, say they have stomach gags with it,
but let's say it took them, it's food, and that went away.
The only thing is that liver issue because it's anybody getting liver pain and the inflammation
of liver that could damage your liver. See, it's got to keep an eye on that.